You're not going to get a chance to see
the future. Once you're reborn again.
They, this life, when you come back, do
you want to have a memory of your past?
You don't, you don't get think it's
a part of the system I think. Yeah,
I think it's evil either whether
it's voluntary or involuntary.
It's best to not know where
you came from at first.
It's best to figure it out.
That's probably what this is
all about is figuring it out.
Cause when we go to the movie, part
of it is, it's all about the journey.
It's not about the destination.
People always use that as a, you know,
an Instagram. It's not about the journey.
And so it's not about the destination.
It's the journey.
That's one of the most popular saying
it's Everett and it's beautiful.
You have to say it every now and then
to remind you, remind the rum. Well My,
another thing to remind you, you don't
even think about it as a journey.
Just be in the moment except the moment
and be in the moment. Live in the moment.
Think about the future plan for the
future. But exist in the moment. You know,
don't think of it as a
journey or a destination,
but the people that are the most fucked
or the people that are trying to make it
one day I'm going to make it. And
then when you make, there's no making.
It never happens. So it
doesn't, it doesn't change.
It doesn't matter if you're an illusion.
I fell for it. Hook, line and sinker.
Oh my God. The wanting to be
a rock star my whole life.
They got me good. I wanted that man
shit. Oh, I was going to have that man.
She just filled, you know, with
the shakes and then go back.
So that's what I was after my whole life.
They got me good.
When I saw kiss and I saw that shit, I'm
like, I want that. I knew, right, right.
When I saw kiss meets the
phantom of the park, 1978 on NBC,
one of the worst movies of all time.
It just blew me the fuck away.
There was a power outage.
All my God, I was watching it at home.
The power went out and I was devastated.
The weird thing about that, that arrows
in 1978 and if you followed kiss,
if you were old and I was eight and if
you follow a kiss from 73 [inaudible]
they already had their early cool years
and then after kiss alive that a few
more awesome albums and then they got
to the point where they started doing
disco and that was 1978 that's when I
got into them when they started doing
disco. So I didn't, I didn't
even know what selling out was.
I just heard I was made for loving
it. I loved it. You know what I mean?
I had no idea. But um, man, I don't
even know what my fucking point was.
What were we talking about?
I don't remember either.
The point was you're never going to
get to know what the future holds.
You just going to be living your life
and that's how it is with everybody.
I don't remember what the fuck your
point was. The Rock Star thing though,
you Roxanne to be a rock star.
They get you. They get, you could,
there's so many different ways
they can, like you get your,
you get yourself too. I mean, you gotta,
you gotta think about what you're exposed
to, but look, it's like music videos,
what they sell in music videos. They sell
that. It's like they're offering book.
I got and, and a lot of those
rappers that are flashing on a cash,
it's not even their money. It's
not even there, their mansion.
But it's pushing that,
pushing like you want to do whatever
it takes, whatever it takes to make it.
I was so zeroed in on that, you know, me
up, up until up until a few years ago.
How was the zeroed on it? Uh, then I
began to realize, wow, they got me real.
God damn good. You know, I was
obsessed with some, some, uh,
an illusion.
Fame is an illusion.
Obsessed with the destination
instead of the journey. Right. Well,
I enjoyed the journey, but it was like,
no, I'm saying that you're obsessed with,
it was all about conquering the music
business. That's all it was about.
And it's not about that
anymore, obviously. Thank God,
thank God I sucked musically because if
I would've had a record deal and my 20s
shit, I would have did some
crazy illuminati shit back then.
I would've did whatever
I should like whatever.
Just I would have been to those parties
with the crazy mask and been doing.
I'm like, let's go have parties
with a crazy man. I was like, shut.
They just let you, the guidewire hit
album, they're like, Hey Eddie, they
come off California.
Come on down.
Thank God my music sucked because I would
have went along with all that shit in
my twenties I was so obsessed.
I was so obsessed with making
it in the music business.
I would have did any of the home,
but you wouldn't have done that.
Gone part of the Jimmy Savile.
I would have been hanging out
with whoever was famous, you know?
Well,
you know,
it's like retirement is a lesser example
that people are always looking for
those golden years.
One day I'm going to retire and we're
going to be working with our hands at the
sunset. Like, no, you're thinking
about death then don't do shit anymore.
And you don't have nothing to do.
You know,
the only time you should think about
retirement is if you have a job that you
can retire and they pay you still,
and then you can go do
whatever the fuck you want.
That's what you should be
thinking about retiring.
But thinking about as this time
where high to leave, we get to relax.
We put our feet up and then they turn
you into soylent green, turn you a foot.
That's what we're really aiming for.